on the future of England Captain Harry
Kane later on this NewsHour
[Music]
well we have some breaking news now
Israel's military says it stopped an
attempt to damage the northern border
fence with Lebanon the Reuters news
agency is reporting that several members
of the Hezbollah armed group were
wounded the Israeli Army says a
non-lethal force was used to keep them
at Bay well for more on this let's bring
in Imran Khan who is on the line for us
from occupied East Jerusalem Imran I
know this has all just happened in the
last few hours what more do we know at
the stage
well I can tell you that the Israeli
Army isn't confirming that this is
Hezbollah in fact what they've actually
said is a number of suspects approached
the security board offense from Lebanon
from uh the Lebanese side and then they
try to attract attack that border uh the
military force and monitor them and as
you say he used what they mean what they
say is non-lethal force to expel them
probably likely to be tear gas or
something around that uh that's when
they say that the identity of the people
is unknown and that's actually quite
crucial because this is a very tense
border and a wrong accusation a a false
accusation could spark things now the
Army confirmed that they are going to
still do carry on their work there in
defense of the sovereignty of resolve
but that's not something that has Fuller
actually agree with that have been
tension along this Border in the start
of July Israel actually put a concrete
walls around 11 is half of a city there
on the border called Gadget now that's
the city uh Israel has been occupied
since the end of the 2006 War in April
there were at least 30 Rockets fired
into from Lebanon into Northern Israel
every we bought at that stage that
Israel would react it did but not
perhaps in the way that it we thought it
might actually just hit empty field then
last week uh there was a mortar attack
um from that area uh into Israel it was
just one water that fell
um Israeli security sources here have
been suggesting that it was a
Palestinian group and not Hezbollah that
were responsible uh for that but no
group was taken official responsibility
so this idea
um that it could be Hezbollah uh it
could be another another group is is
something that Israel takes incredibly
seriously because right now uh if
there's an attack on Hezbollah then
Hamas will react out of Gaza and the
Syrian groups will react out of uh Syria
as well because all three of those
groups see an attack on one as an attack
on all of them and they'll all react and
Israel really doesn't want that kind of
level of warfare if generals have long
said publicly uh that they're looking to
contain tensions on that border now uh
in the past say six months we have seen
tension slightly increase on that border
but it seems to be a very managed
response and counter response from both
that side of the border the Lebanese
side of the border and the Israeli side
of Border still a very sensitive
situation Imran Khan there with the
latest for us from occupied East
Jerusalem well let's now bring in she
joins us on the line too but from the
Lebanese Capital Beirut Asana Imran was
just saying there that these men haven't
been identified what are you hearing
there from the Lebanese side
yes the Israeli Army not confirming it
Hezbollah but a Hezbollah spokesperson
is being quoted by
um the local media as saying that in
fact these were Hezbollah members three
Hezbollah members wounded in an incident
so the Hezbollah spokesperson who was
quoted by the local media saying the
circumstances
um are still not clear so not saying
that this was an attack attack that the
Israeli Army is saying that there was an
attempt to to sabotage or thwart the
fence that divides these two countries
um really there has been a lot of
tension and this is what Imran has been
you know was talking about but today the
timing is quite significant because
Lebanon and in particular Hezbollah
commemorates the the 17th anniversary of
the last war the last major award fought
with Israel in 2006 and there were what
we understand were activists along the
border some of them were demonstrating
and others even there were reports that
others even set a fire so clearly both
sides have been provoking each other for
in in recent weeks we saw Hezbollah set
up outposts in in disputed territory
because this border is still not
internationally recognized and they're
still disputed areas along this border
we've seen Israel a set up a fence
around an area claimed by Lebanon so
both sides really provoking each other
now neither one neither once War this is
um this this has been clear for some
time now because of the way that they
react to certain to certain incidents
but what is interesting is that there's
now talk about the possibility of
demarcating the border the land border
between the two countries there are
reports that an American mediator is
expected in Beirut
um and to to start discussing this issue
with officials here so um this incident
is unlikely to lead to a flare-up or
some sort of Confrontation they're
sending messages to each other they're
provoking each other they're seeing how
far each other uh how how far they can
push each other for the time being
against the backdrop of the possibility
of negotiations
with the latest forest from the Lebanese
Capital Beirut will be getting you more
details as we get them here on Al
Jazeera
a Palestinian president Mahmoud Abbas
has visited Janine for the first time in
more than 10 years this comes days after